my mom killed Santa Claus and this is  that story so I go to school and I am  basically asking all my friends what  they're asking Santa for Christmas this  one kid overhears me and he goes you  know Santa isn't real right and I'm like  other kids they're starting to chime in  and be like yeah Victoria and I was just  thinking about how I'm going to prove  all of them wrong so I get in the car  and I am plotting and planning with my  mom she's just like yeah kid whatever  what do you want for dinner and I'm like  Chinese dude that Chinese food gave my  mom food poisoning my mom's throwing up  in the bathroom I want an American Girl  doll Barbie Dreamhouse mom and she is  just like kid shut up  yells at me from the bathroom Santa's  dead I'm crying so hard that my mom is  puking and now I'm puking and to this  day my mom still writes from Santa on  all of my gifts